the moment you lace up the skates and
step out onto the ice you never really
know what's going to happen one hit for
one bounce can change the outcome of a
game or an entire season whether you're
chasing down a rolling puck powering
your way to the friendly men we're
splitting the D to avoid a devastating
hit we wanted to kill fifteens physics
to capture the unpredictability
physicality every play in the NHL thanks
to the power of new consoles physics can
now be applied to each and every player
on the ice through the new 12-player
collision physics this result of
authentic multiplayer collisions and the
chaos that comes from a last-minute
scramble for a loose puck within that
physical chaos there is still a punk ed
to control and NHL 15 punk physics has
been completely overhauled pucks can hop
over sticks squeeze through an opening
and the flood unpredictably to create
doors and scenarios not possible
stay tuned for upcoming dev Diaries he
trained board gameplay improvements
living worlds and the aldi broadcast
team of dog camera and Eddie Olczyk in
NHL 15 experience the next generation of
hockey for yourself when initial 15
drops on September 9